[Musique]
voilà donc là on peut faire quelque
chose on peut faire une belle vie ah
Monsieur le Maire donc là tout est à
faire d'accord on a un très bon
emplacement est-ce que vous croyez que
ça serait possible de se spécialiser un
peu dans le jeu le tourisme le loisir
pour que l'indice de bonheur soit assz
élevé que les gens viennent dans ma
ville c'est une bonne stratégie loisir
et plaisir du citoyen est-ce que voulez
qu'on lancez
par s'il vous
plat coup de GR dans la façade et dans
les
fondations il faire descre tout ça on va
faireutre chose que bâtiment il en veut
plus le maire non quoi il faut faire
descendre en fait j'ai changé d'avis et
donc ce qu'on va mettre à la place on va
mettre un stadium ça ça va être un stade
voyez ce que je veux dire euh ça oui oui
ça sert à rien est-ce qu'on peut faire
descendre le casino s'il vous plaît e
les gars on va faire descendre le casino
écartez-vous reculez un peu fais
descendre voilà là ça devrait arriver
ouais je comprends pas il y a un
problème de connexion je pense qu'il y a
un problème de WiFi vous êtes le chef de
chantier faudrait demander au gar qui
s'écte parce on va faire DESC de
casino demander qui faire ça c'est moi
parceen fait j'aimerais bien un casino
dans ma
ville alors je vais vous expliquer parce
que dans la ville voisine ils ont déjà
commencé à mettre de zones
résidentielles moi ce que j'aimerais
faire c'est de récupérer les habitants
de résidentielle en me spécialisant dans
les loisirs et dans le jeu donc je vais
aussi mettre un casino on a choisi
celui-là regardez regardez voilà ce que
je voudrais si possible donc là qu'on
finisse pour ce soir les résidences les
deux bureaux on fasse un centre
commercial et puis juste tous les
loisirs ok on peut faire ça oui c'est
antisismique les zones c'est
antisismique oui c'est antisismique oui
donc ouais mais s'il y a des comètes
c'est pareil ça changera rien s'il y a
des comètes faudrait construire un
bouclier en adabum je crois que c'est
c'est pas impossible mais ça coûte
beaucoup de Sim FL faut vous le dire
Monsieur le Maire oui B non non non mais
de toute façon on va on va faisons pas
le bouclier c'est pas très grave est-ce
que là tu peux me mettre une fusse pour
Godzilla que si Godzilla il se ramène il
va tout défoncer tu comprends parce que
ce bâtiment là il va essayer de monter
dessus c'est sûr l'autre solution c'est
de planter ici de la forêt et lui si un
godzillac arrive il va brouter vous avez
raison mais moi la forêt ça me plaît pas
parce que la forêt ça rapporte rien
alors que ça peut-être qu'on peut mettre
installer de éoliennes c'est vachement
bien c'est une super idée comme ça ça
rapporte ça ça approvisionne en énergie
et en même temps ça correspond à
l'indice de bonheur des habitants on
peut faire ça tenez je vous donne ça
vous le faites là vous pouvez le
lancer comment il s'appelle EDID ID je
peux ID tu m'entends 5/ 5 tu me fais
descendre les deux éoliennes s'il te
plaît quoi il y a rien il y a rien là là
depuis qu'on est tout à l'heure ça a pas
du tout bougé on a demandé deux
éoliennesasy pas on a demandé un casino
il est où ou mais qu'est-ce que je fais
avec la rue vous
descends-moi c'est c'est à moi je vous
les ai acheté a 5000 SIM qui sont partis
sur l'éolien j'ai cliqué donc maintenant
je voudrais juste qu'elle descend faut
aller voir buauprès vous venez
on faites que des bureaux
là on en veut un peu moi j'en veux un
peu c'est intéressant voilà ce qu'on va
faire
a quand même une autre gueule que ce
qu'il y a derrière on a la zone du
bureau qu'on va conserver VO comme ça
avoir cet esprit là vous avez un esprit
per on va perd jeu franchement vous nous
facilitez pas le gameplay je vous le
[Musique]
dis